on this episode I bring zero energy I
answered the questions extremely well
and I talked about I don't know I don't
remember you keep asking questions I'll
keep trying to answer them everybody
this is Gary Vaynerchuk this is episode
25 the askgaryvee show fun fact about
number 25
Calvin Pryor where's number 25 for two
Jet's first round pick that hurt
yesterday kartik asks what do you look
for when hiring creatives Kartika great
question creatives are really
interesting hire here at vaynermedia
because in the agency world the creative
process is very romantic by my point of
view meaning that a lot of people care
about winning awards a lot of people
want to make movies and TV shows and
that whatever reason they are now in the
advertising industry and they're caring
more about the craft than they are about
the agenda which is to sell coffee to
sell whatever this thing is to sell
phones and so you know to me what I'm
looking for in creatives are people that
are very creative and still want to make
the greatest creative that they're
capable of but also something that's
grounded in the fact that we're here to
sell stuff and if we don't ultimately
move product or inspire people to donate
or make them aware about a cause we are
not going to be fulfilling the duty at
hand and so I'm looking for a level of
practicality and a little hint of 2015
data understanding for my creatives
which i think is a little bit of a
different spin megan asks you're like a
billionaire right what do you splurge on
Megan I'm not even sure if I'm a hundred
million err maybe with my assets
you know vaynermedia and Wine Library
are doing well but I splurge on
experiences for example LeBron first
game back in Cleveland against my Knicks
as you noticed today I'm wearing orange
because I'm starting to get ready for
the basketball season you can imagine
why so experiences you know vacations
with my family and definitely like
things like
LeBron's first came back in Cleveland
and they play the Knicks AJ's a huge
Knicks fan
more so than even I am let's go with him
to that something me and my bro can
remember when we're much older it's cool
to like sit around if you're an old man
right now and be like remember one
whipped creams first game back in
Milwaukee with the Lakers that's like a
fun story that those are kind of things
I want to spend money on experiences
paying for my friends to go on trips
when I was younger when they couldn't
afford it I splurged on spending time
with people that I care about hey Gary
so preseason hockey is on mighty seas
the Washington Capitals with a pumpkin
okay still anyway been following them
since I was a kid kind of like you and
the Jets and so I started let's go
snapchat account about a month and a
half ago and I've been pretty
disappointed with the content that
they've been posting they're just
wondering if you owned a hockey team
what kind of things would you do a
snapchat Kevin good question thank you
like your background also one of my
fondest sports moments was the 1986
Rangers defeating Lang way and carpenter
and Gardner and those boys from
Washington so thanks for that win uh
you're probably too young for that but
that was a big one for me um you know I
think snapchat is if I owned the Rangers
right now what I would be doing with
snapchat is recognizing that it's skews
young so I try to put out content that
people 13 to 25 would give a crap about
so behind the scenes videos doing good
stories I would definitely draw on top
of pictures I would take pictures of the
players and draw funny faces on them do
little contests that were very inside to
that community meaning knowing excuse
young doing a take a screenshot of this
snap bring it and will let you skate on
the ice things that really engaged the
psychology of the demo on the platform
and basically I rinse and repeat that
everywhere 40 year old woman on
Pinterest what's her psychology on it
she wants a shop that's the kind of
stuff I want to give there you know 13
to 25 year old on snapchat what does he
or she want to see on snapchat silly fun
stuff because that's what's going on
right now recognizing it's not for my 40
year old season ticket holder so I would
play to that psychology
muscle company asks how do you generate
novel ideas and an overpopulated
seemingly stale industry the fitness
industry for example the muscle company
I kind of like saying that the muscle
company I always find the best way to
attack an industry that you're in and is
stale and you want to innovate by
spending zero time in it one little fun
fact that most people don't know is I
spent them awful excuse me an extreme
lack of time within the wine industry
and within the agency in the stream I
don't think I've ever been I've been to
like six other agencies in my life
because there were meetings there I know
nothing about it I read nothing about
other agencies that add age spend no
time asking my senior people about what
they did at other agencies when I was in
the wine business everyone's like you
should go check out this store in Dallas
they're doing X I'm like I don't give a
crap for me the way I've always been
innovative is lack of education and I'm
not joking I tend to stay within myself
and what comes natural and to I look to
other industries so if I were you I'd be
paying attention to what's happening in
the food industry or you know in the
rock climbing industry or things
completely left field like hip-hop or
sports or just stuff that has nothing to
do with your industry because the best
way to stay within the zone and not
innovating is pay attention to everybody
else because they're doing the same crap
- Joe asks with the NFL in London this
week what do you think about sports
franchises moving to different cities or
countries I think some sports franchises
should go to very far away places like
as far from here as possible this was
episode 25 of the askgaryvee show
question of the day I don't know one of
the first three websites you look at
every morning you keep asking questions
I'll keep answering them fun fact about
number 25 Calvin Pryor where's number 25
for the Jets first round pick got hurt
yesterday
funny did get hurt I didn't know what I
was gonna say about sweating my buddy
literally got her unbelievable all right
oh crap wait subscribe I need
subscriptions because I can't push this
many right hooks in social